Hey,
why did you have a piece of paper with Sasuke's name written on it? Why
did you call my name? What is your relationship with Sappek?
Mr. I was picking up that letter
Come on,
calm down like that, calm down and throw it masa This
guy, this
guy, Europe, burnt, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, eh, the
city will answer all the questions about the stars
In the first place, these guys are hugely enthusiastic readers of my flirting paradise
.
After reading the book, I became interested and
went out of my way to visit Konohagakure no Sato to study all the people and things related to the legs.
It's because he must be someone related to the city,
but why did he participate in combat training even though he wasn't a ninja?
I think it's my own disease Because of a
sense of mission Your name
Weight  I got caught up in
it so violently that I'm going to have a gas tomorrow
.